[Applause]
taiwan is a fascinating experiment
in terms of democratization you've got a
relatively liberal society one way that
people have seen that globally is that
it's
the first place in asia to legalize
same-sex marriage
it's an island of less than 24 million
people and yet
its economy is close to one of the top
20 in the world today
but this wealthy democratic island is
not considered an independent country by
beijing
china has long viewed taiwan as its lost
territory
and threatened to unify with it by force
into the taiwan
under beijing's pressure only 15 states
in the world
recognize taiwan today down from 23 in
2016
and one key country is not on that list
the united states the us is taiwan's
biggest ally
although there are no formal diplomatic
relations between the two
the us is taiwan's biggest armed
supplier
has close economic ties with the island
and
is likely to defend it we are going to
hold china accountable to follow the
rules
so how has taiwan become the most
volatile issue
between the world's two greatest powers
up to the late 19th century taiwan then
known as
passed through the rule of dutch and
spanish colonizers
its aboriginal peoples and chinese
dynasties
in 1895 the qing dynasty of china
lost taiwan to japan after a humiliating
military defeat
taiwan was then ruled by the japanese
for the following
50 years japan wanted to make taiwan
into a model colony
using it as an example to persuade other
asian nations to join the japanese
empire they raised living standards
they improved education they improved
health
and built a lot of infrastructure so
that 50 years later taiwan was actually
one of the more developed parts
of the region after world war ii
taiwan was returned to the control of
the chinese government at that point the
republic of china
the republic of china rapidly lost the
chinese civil war to
the communist party of china
and as a result ended up on taiwan as a
regime in
exile with very few resources a lot of
refugees
very poor populations struggling to
survive
taiwan relied heavily on u.s economic
aid
but by the middle of the 1960s most of
that aid was
phased out as the u.s wanted taiwan to
develop
its own economy so taiwan changed its
strategy
moving from an import substitution
policy which replaced
foreign imports with home-made goods to
an
export-oriented economy and taiwan
moved very very quickly towards
exporting very cheap
mostly consumer goods to the united
states and as a consequence over the
next 20 to 30 years
taiwan's economy boomed
so beginning in the 1980s the the
government in taiwan started to
think how do we take the next step in
our economic development and they
identified among many areas
semiconductors as a critical
technology and so that really took off
in the 1990s
with the growth of taiwan semiconductor
manufacturing
company that eventually you know now
today
is an absolutely crucial company for any
company that's making
technology you know their their chips
are in smartphones they're in tablets
they're in computers they're in games
consoles and they're in cars as well
anything that you need chips for largely
you're having to come to tsmc and so
this by extension
puts taiwan in a fairly strong position
that it is a key node in the tech supply
chain
globally and so it is a really really
valuable partner for
every single country in the world
alongside this economic shift
taiwan's political landscape also
changed dramatically
under the rule of the chinese
nationalist party or kmt
for four decades taiwan was an
authoritarian regime
until the end of martial law in the late
1980s
then taiwan gradually transitioned to
democracy
the first direct presidential elections
took place in 1996
followed by several peaceful transfers
of power
so the democratic progressive party is
the current party that
governs taiwan they were a party that
came out of this movement of activists
pushing
for more democracy in taiwan in the
1970s
and their fundamental stance is that
taiwan is already an independent country
but this isn't the same stance held by
beijing
so from the people's republic of china
the prc's perspective
taiwan remains the last piece of an
unfinished civil war
it's an illegitimate regime it's a
breakaway territory that needs to be
unified with the motherland the jian
kai-shek regime
won a reprieve in june 1950 when the
korean war broke out
the united states then stepped in to
prevent a final
chinese communist party ccp led invasion
of the island of taiwan the united
states has been there ever since as the
guarantor of taiwan's security
despite this guarantee of security in
1979 the u.s broke
ties with the republic of china on
taiwan and established them with the
people's republic of china in beijing
here things get complicated the united
states
in one of our communiques with the
people's republic of china
acknowledged the prc position
that taiwan was part of china but the
united states also did not
accept the prc claim to taiwan
that has been our position ever since
and so in effect
the u.s views taiwan's status
as undetermined even after 1979 they
have maintained
informal relations with taiwan and
continued to
invest here continue to support the
economy and have most importantly
continued
to sell arms to taiwan
with the us in the middle china and
taiwan have avoided war for over seven
decades but tensions between the two
sides have risen in recent years
emerging as a superpower on the world
stage china has become
more assertive in its claims of
sovereignty over taiwan
while most of the taiwanese prefer
maintaining the status quo
for now many young people favor overt
independence for taiwan
the young people have really been at the
heart of this political transformation
we're seeing in taiwan over the past
eight nine years where they started
pushing back against
this economic integration between uh
china and taiwan
that started under former president
mayan joe one of the best examples
was the sunflower movement that broke
out in march of 2014
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this movement was led mostly by college
students
opposed to negotiations with beijing
over a free trade agreement
the movement occupied the legislative
yen taiwan's parliament
for more than three weeks in order to
block that parliament from considering
this trade agreement and voting on it so
in effect
the sunflower movement protesters
blocked
further economic integration with
mainland china
taiwanese podcasters kylie wang and ken
young
joined some of the rallies and marches
and started their popular news show
during the movement we have mixed
feelings towards china
because on one hand i know that a lot of
young people want to explore the
big market in china because china have
just much more opportunity and sometimes
even better salaries nowadays yeah
especially for those who just graduate
from college
on the other hand just china just keep
on bullying us
we just don't like what they're doing we
want to have
economic growth but we do not want to
sacrifice our economic growth
with our freedom of speech with our
independence
with our democracy
since the sunflower movement the
china-friendly kmt party has seen its
polling numbers decline
steeply while the dpp leader tsai
ingwen won the presidential elections in
2016
and was re-elected in 2020 so she
has as her bottom line effectively that
taiwan is an independent sovereign
nation her stance is that we're willing
to talk
but only as equals and that is obviously
a position that beijing is unwilling to
accept
china cut official communications with
taiwan in 2016
and stopped individual travel permits to
the island in 2019
it's also upped the rhetoric on taking
control of taiwan
and increased military maneuvers all of
which is a concern for the us
taiwan is by far the most likely issue
to draw the united states and china into
a direct military conflict
i should say i don't think the
likelihood of that is particularly high
still but it overshadows all
other potential points of friction in
the u.s china relationship
if china and taiwan did eventually go to
war
there could be a devastating cost to
human life
and industry even if china manages
they could spend years rebuilding taiwan
and struggle to integrate a hostile
population
also be an incredibly dangerous messy
affair
the attempt to invade a fortified island
is always going to be an incredibly
difficult one so there's a very good
reason they have not
attempted to take taiwan by military
force it's because they're not sure they
can do so
and so it would be a really disastrous
event for everybody involved
and there's a very good chance that
other democracies in this region
certainly japan maybe australia would
get drawn in as well
you know put quite simply it's in
everybody's best interest
right now not to force the issue and to
push it off for another
few years or maybe even a few decades
but the unification would signal to the
world
that it's china not the us that's the
new dominant power in the region
being able to bring taiwan into the prc
fold
would be obviously be a huge achievement
for any chinese leader
and you know it's largely seen as being
as one of his ambitions
to achieve before he steps down whenever
that may be
taiwan's future really depends how if
our allies would take china seriously
no i would say it depends on the
attitudes of the western countries
towards china
because if the western countries for
example the u.s
uh start to see taiwan as an important
geopolitical ally
then taiwan could become a beacon of
democracy in the chinese-speaking world
if not the western countries would like
to see
china growing over to influence over the
world then
they can just let china be and yeah and
we will be in real risk
yeah taiwan might be in a real risk the
trump administration
showed strong support for taiwan by
providing more weapons
sending high-level officials to visit
and changing the law to make
interactions between the two sides much
easier
in june a u.s delegation visited taipei
and announced plans to donate
750 000 doses of covet 19 vaccines
to help alleviate its shortage of shots
since biden has taken office
the people he's put in place so far at
least have repeated
the trump administration's position on
taiwan and have actually taken quite
strong stands in favor of that approach
to taiwan
ignoring or pushing back against
beijing's objections
but obviously we'll have to see over the
next four potentially eight years to see
how strong that support for taiwan
actually is
you